I mean the logic of education reform is
to always call for more education reform
hi I'm Nicolas tree with reason TV and
today we're talking with Andrew Ferguson
he's a senior editor at The Weekly
Standard the author most recently of
crazy you won dad's crash course in
getting his kid into college and he's
got a great story in the current Weekly
Standard called the Common Core
commotion haven't we seen this movie
before so you're writing about Common
Core the common core standards it's the
latest iteration of a big national
educational standards reform tell us
before we get into it explain what
common core is well I think it's
actually called common core of state
standards but it's national standards
and why state standards would be called
national standards as part as the whole
mess that is involved there what it is
is the product of a bunch of governors
got together and hired some educational
experts to go off into somewhere we
don't know where and write a kalila yeah
or wherever the Fed nap right right
right probably Kiowa I'll be under
somewhere like that but anyway and they
came back with what are called standards
as opposed to curriculum now what I
didn't quite realize is that a national
curriculum is actually prohibited by law
in the Charter the Department of
Education you're not allowed it's it's
grounds for blowing up the whole
department if if they said the common
core standards I mean they don't say
okay in first grade you must teach
George Washington did this that and the
other thing but they say by the end of
1st grader the end of fifth grader the
end of high school you should possess
these sorts of capacities these skills
being able to read with care and and
outline what you've read the math
standards have various very generalized
skills that you should be able to
achieve without any content to them what
one of the problems but but it's also
that they couldn't put content in
because if they did then it would become
a national right and then and then they
would really have gotten why did that
why did the governor's do this and then
explain the intersection between the
kind of governors coming together to
push this and the Obama administration
well it's it's partly a bastard child of
this awful thing called No Child Left
Behind that started under bush with with
the aid of edward kennedy and it was a
great people who really believed in
bipartisanship really want to take a
look at what bipartisanship produces it
was so bipartisan by the end of as it
was being implemented everybody involved
with it it would say hey I had nothing
and yeah oh of course in one but one
people say well the standards behind I
feel people say you didn't put enough
money into it and all that stuff anyway
it failed miserably for reasons that are
not terribly complicated that you'd
guess is that they were supposed to test
their students and they started lying
about how well their students were doing
because they got more money the better
their students were doing so the
governor's kind of were embarrassed into
getting together and trying to do
something where instead of having 50
different state standards you would have
one or two sets of standards that
everybody had to meet and then everybody
would be happy and we would all become
Shakespeare scholar well and then the
federal government gets involved because
they can I mean they can't command
anybody to do this but they can direct a
lot of money if you play ball with them
so talk a little bit about that well the
way that happened was I mean the way
they became national standards was you
remember the great Obama's stimulus in
two thousand and I'm still waiting yeah
it's really quite uh you know because
among the most fascinating things about
that is that the government could not
even spend the money fast the way I mean
it failed at spending money that was
going to start the economy right
absolutely well one of the ways they
were going to do it was give a whole
bunch to the Department of Education and
they didn't quite know what to do with
it but they were big fans of this idea
of common standards right so they took a
pot of money close to a billion dollars
actually threw two and a half billion
dollars and said to the states we're
going to give you this but you know you
have to meet a couple of condition
one of them is you should agree to a set
of common standards among yourselves and
so of course the state's this is in the
recession get out of the state's say
give us the money and we'll agree to
whatever you tell us you know one of the
things that motivates the idea of having
kind of common standards seems to be you
know it's it's a conservative goldwing
you know conservatives want to tend to
want to have a single language national
language that won't have a national
history national catechism but then with
school they become a pope lechtig and
conservatives and libertarians and
increasingly teachers unions are really
anti-common core but before we get to
that what is you know is there what is
bad about having 50 different states
dictating what their kids should know if
not even more I mean in 1950 there were
over a hundred thousand school districts
in America now there's something like
under fourteen thousand you know that
kind of consolidation is generally we
wouldn't say that's a good thing in
business why why do we want to
consolidate in educational vision for K
through 12 education which point out is
something like 650 billion dollars a
year goes into the K through 12 well
this is part of the logic of education
reform and the logic of education reform
is to always call for more education
reform when it was decided that this was
going to become a national priority back
in the late 70s early 80s that we had to
raise standards to raise test scores and
this starts in a way with it was
actually Jimmy Carter created the
Department of Education in 79 right
Reagan of course ran on getting rid of
it that was one of his campaign planks
but then by the mid 80s he had come up
with a nation at risk yeah which helps
touch roundly influential report saying
that we were all going to hell in a
handbasket but it extends back beyond
that you know in the 1950s there was a
very very big and influential book
called what Ivan knows that Johnny
doesn't and it was why are these people
these little kids in the Soviet Union
being able to build Sputnik you know and
we can bear all our kids are hanging out
at the soda fountain oh yeah chocolate
malts yeah getting a guy Ricky runs yeah
poodle skirts so yeah but anyway so this
is a long-standing heart of a kind of
American self-flagellation is that
schools are going to hell and
there's just no way that you can have
that kind of national sentiment without
the mobilizing this huge federal
apparatus and it's starting to impose
why do do conservatives dislike the idea
of Common Core because it's the wrong
core or because it's common the the the
answer to that is both the is a
scattershot objection among
conservatives a lot of it is based on
misinformation you know you'll read the
conservative websites and blogs and
they'll say Common Core mandates that
fourth graders learn how to masturbate
so you know and that's yeah baloney and
they've taken that out of a book that
claims to be aligned with a common core
so they're all these scare stories and
urban legends going around and that is
created a lot of the animosity towards
it the other thing is just the
principled objection which if you're
getting at which is that you just cannot
unify standards and run roughshod over
what has always been considered a local
obligation which is schooling the you
know well you let me just so yeah it's a
wire the wire the union's piss now well
they weren't at the beginning because as
this money was rolling out from private
foundations the Gates Foundation lots of
other places the unions were spending it
and they were quite happy to receive it
and talk a little bit about the role
before we get to the union's objections
now built the bill and melinda gates
foundation along with the government has
been pumping lots of money they you know
they say we want better schools because
better schools make better citizens or
better employees is more like it so we
need to up our game you know and then
how do how do they spend money and how
are they dictating kind of the course of
education well to it to a large extent
education reforming the united states as
a creature of the Gates Foundation he
spent more than a billion dollars on
secondary in primary education in the
last few years he has a thing about
training teachers its costume 335
million dollars over three years and
it's born absolutely no fruit whatsoever
i but you if he's seeding the ground
with
all this money they're going to be a lot
of people who are happy to take it and
they're going to be happy to tell him
what he wants to hear which is at the
common core is the way to go now what's
happening with the unions is that
basically in certain places common core
is starting to bite Common Core requires
schools to test their kids according to
a pre-approved standardized tests and
then teachers are going to be held
responsible for what those results are
on those tests the unions are fine would
almost anything in education except for
holding teachers accountable for how
much learning is going on is it fair to
I mean or it is there a fair way to
judge how much a teacher how much impact
a teacher has had on a student or are
they right to be kind of like you know
we know from the No Child Left Behind
tests that a lot of districts you know
we'd game things and they would screw
around to make sure that the test scores
were good are they I mean should we be
sympathetic to teachers saying luckier
you're you know all I can do is get
screwed on this yeah sure you know and
there are a lot of great teachers but
there are also a lot of really crappy
teachers and if you ever spend any time
in an education school and you read the
curriculums of these Department of
Education and major universities it's
total crap and how is it what do you
mean by that because it focuses on the
process of teaching rather than subject
it's all a sort of abstract theory about
how to teach not there's a little bit
about how to teach but not what you're
going to teach kids so somebody will
graduate with an education degree and be
told to teach history but they've never
really learned anything about American
history right european history or
whatever it is so they're teaching them
how to teach by according to theory and
so as most people have now learned you
can get an education degree almost
anywhere it when you go to a large
University and it's famous for the place
where everybody gets dumped to can't
really do anything else and so we've had
lots of teachers who are the product of
that system and and now the teachers
unions are saying no to common core or
they're pushing back there yes more or
less usually it's happening at the local
level like the Chicago the AFT the
American Federation of Teachers is not
officially against common core but the
local chapter in Chicago one of the
largest in fact maybe the largest
chapter the FT is now passed a
resolution saying they don't want Common
Core they don't want the tests to be
implemented there is what about 45
states have have signed on common core
and a number now are pulling it out or
are questioning it is this going to
become kind of like the Real ID if you
remember the or i guess it was you know
years ago where there was going to be
standardized you know requirements for
government IDs for driver's license
especially that would tie into this than
the other thing and as it actually
approached implementation it you know
suddenly I states were like hey forget
it right I'm done with well and that's
what happened with no child left behind
by the time No Child Left Behind became
uncomfortable for people it's just
falling apart and so common core has
risen to take its place in the same
thing I can't see in a way in which the
same thing doesn't happen to common core
where the minute it starts to make
people uncomfortable it exists but only
as a husk what you know but and then
something will arise to replace it
though because we're already there must
be generation 3,000 or whatever I mean
there's like a new education reform plan
being cooked up right right pretty soon
it will be why does one what is one ho
know that Johnny doesn't it will be you
know we'll use the Chinese is the great
button then everybody the Danes every
but you know whatever it is there will
always be a reason to mobilize this huge
apparatus of education is there any
reason to believe that American
education is definitely on purple bases
k through 12 since the early 70s has
gone up depending on who you listen to
at least twice we're spending at least
twice in real dollars per pupil maybe as
much as three results are flat so the
schools are getting more expensive but
they're not necessarily getting worse is
there a crisis in American education
where is one of the reasons why none of
these programs work is because there
really isn't a crisis to be fun well if
there is a crisis the test scores are
pretty bad on an international scale we
do spend more than by far than at per
pupil than any other country in the
world but wait wait that
in health care the fact that we spend
more than any other countries this time
we have to cut spending but we have to
spend more well as I say all reports a
logic to reform all reform gets more
reform yeah the problem with it is
though in identifying where for example
test scores you've got right outside
here you're in your palatial offices of
reason you have some of the highest
performing schools in the world 10
blocks away you have some of the worst
performing schools in the world so what
do you do you come into the District of
Columbia and you impose some kind of
some kind of abstract program about how
you're going to raise test scores well
what about the really good scores that
come out of it and you know it's just
there's no blindness on the state level
to I mean you mentioned in your story
are there states like Massachusetts and
Indiana and Utah that actually do
extremely well in terms of you know as
student now comes across the board and
and it's not clear that applying those
standards to other states is going to
work at all no and the trail have caused
effect even in places like Massachusetts
which has been very successful according
to test scores it's not clear why
they've been so successful there are
certain things they've done that would
be worthy of emulation by other states
but nobody can trace so is there do you
have a preferred vision or what you know
what is the best way forward everybody
wants at the very least if we're
spending money in education we want the
dollars to be spent more efficiently or
more effectively what if if kind of
concentrating more curricular power or
direction at the at the top isn't going
to work what is what's a better way to
go about actually instituting education
that might make K through 12 schools not
only more bearable for students and
teachers but actually better at
transmitting knowledge yeah well I what
I would do is devolve the entire system
and I think that if there's ever going
to be any remedy it's going to be a
bottom-up remedy it'll be the result of
a radically decentralized curriculum and
all those choices being made at local
levels you're still going to have a
problem about low
schools and there's the temptation to
nationalize education because of that is
going to be very hard to resist which is
why you're still going to get you know
thousands of education experts clamoring
for reform alright well we'll leave it
there the story is the common core
commotion haven't we seen this movie
before and we have and if you have a
particularly good movie yab i'm walking
out next time that's right okay we've
been talking with Andrew Ferguson he's a
senior editor at The Weekly Standard
author most recently of crazy you one
dad's crash course in getting his kid
into college and most recently in the
new issue of the Weekly Standard the
common core commotion haven't we seen
this movie before Andy thanks for
talking about thanks very much for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you